last week YouTuber Sniper Wolf was
accused by Jack's films of doxing him in
front of millions of her Instagram fans
he's called on YouTube to deplatform her
but they've decided to temporarily
demonetize her instead Sniper Wolf has
also come under Fire this week after old
videos of hers have resurfaced that
allegedly show her asking miners to
twerk or Flash her on Omega it's been an
explosive week here's all the details
all right first let's do a very quick
rundown of Sniper Wolf she began her
YouTube career playing FPS games weaving
in more Vlog and lifestyle content over
time by 2017 Sniper Wolf had found her
niche in reaction videos and later
really started blowing up with her Tik
Tok reaction content this made her
extremely successful gaining millions of
subscribers and ostensibly becoming the
face of Tik Tok reaction content now
she's currently sitting at over 30
million subscribers with each video
raking in millions of views Jax films is
one of the OG YouTubers on the platform
he actually made his channel just four
months after YouTube's Creation in 2006
long before the recent debates on the
morality and legality of reaction
content and its effect on creators
Jack's films was already making it very
clear how he felt way back in 2015 he
uploaded a video of him just smiling in
silence at a reactor reacting to a video
of his own to make a point about them
not adding anything of substance to the
original work while still cashing in on
ad revenue and so really it was only a
matter of time before Jack set his
sights on Sniper Wolf in each of her
hundreds and hundreds of videos she
plays other people's Tik toks and
provides extremely Bas level commentary
this dude is running
sideways
what wow if you want to support the
original creators of the Tik toks uh too
bad because the only links you'll find
in the description are all Sniper Wolf
and my favorite part is that half of the
Tik Tok she includes either crop out the
original username or just straight up
don't have one you know the phrase Works
smarter not harder well Sniper Wolf does
neither she just Steals and doesn't
credit anyone and has become a
zillionaire in doing so Jack has even
created a parad Channel called judger
Jack's films that seen him react
exclusively to sniper Wolf's videos
while criticizing what he deemed to be
her low effort content it's all fun and
games until you can't stop yourself this
ended pretty
painlessly what the that was nothing
that whole thing was just like damn that
guy be sliding down the stairs that
could have gone bad but it didn't that's
all you fuing said Sniper Wolf over the
summer the YouTube Creator's Twitter
account quoted Sniper Wolf on her
getting her content ideas from her
community now there are several things
wrong with this tweet like why is she a
keynote speaker at VidCon why is YouTube
creators bolstering this but the worst
thing about the Tweet is this getting
video ideas from her fans what ideas
quite literally all she does is upload
other people's Tik toks how is that an
idea what am I not getting here Jack was
quick to mock this and Sniper Wolf
indirectly replied by claiming 90% of
what she uploads are her own ideas the
back and forth continued with Sniper
Wolf insinuating that Jack's issue with
her was because he can't stand to see a
female YouTuber getting more views than
him in July Jack posted a full
explanation of why he's been calling out
Sniper Wolf including her lack of
crediting the creators she reacts to and
why he feels her videos cross the line
of fair use as well as a rebuttal to her
own accusations of him and then last
week things really took a turn on
October 13th Sniper Wolf posted a story
to her Instagram account in which she
told her fans that her shoot was only 5
minutes from Jack's house and asked them
if she should go and visit him and
that's exactly what she appeared to do
next all right right in front of your
house come out come out and talk to me
he has food outside so he should be out
any minute now to pick it up it's ice
cream as well it's ice
cream I just want to talk Jack's l
reaction to this was actually caught on
stream at the time shut
up minutes wait what she's literally
right outside your oh my God this is
happening right now like call the police
no there's a video she's outside your
house right now Sniper Wolf needs to be
deplatformed in this exact moment she
turned from a mere content Thief to
someone who doxes and stalks her critics
Jack went on to call this a disgusting
abuse of clout and said that if YouTube
allowed this to go unpunished they would
be setting a precedent that it's okay to
docs people if you're a big Creator he
said that if she really wanted to talk
to him there were plenty of ways to do
so but the going to his house crossed
the line he also pushed back on
accusations that in fact he was the one
harassing her saying that his parody
channel was simply critiquing her
non-transformative commentary and
pointing out cases of content theft in
the day since Jack has repeatedly called
for YouTube to enforce their own
harassment policy and remove sniper wol
from YouTube for good at the time
YouTube was accused of making light of
things by posting a tweet that seemed to
be a toned deaf reference to the whole
situation much to the bafflement and
anger of many in the community and this
isn't the only hot water Sniper Wolf has
found herself in recently this week old
YouTube videos of hers have surfaced
that allegedly show her asking miners to
twerk for her or Flash her on Omega the
since deleted videos have been
characterized by some as disturbing at
best or criminal at worst this tweet is
of a Discord bot that allegedly shows
her taking down the videos yeah let's go
come on no come on let's do
it
yeah oh yeah that's awesome yeah let's
get the little guy too I wanted to see
the little guy you can't tell me she
hasn't acknowledged the fact that she's
getting kids to do this on webcam for
her I don't care if it's for a YouTube
video using kids like this to make a
YouTube video especially putting them in
a sexual manner for the content is
nothing short of disgusting some are now
debating whether or not Sniper Wolf was
aware those she was talking to were
underage but many have dismissed this
stating Sniper Wolf knew full well she
was talking to underage Omega users
earlier today YouTube issued an update
in which they said Sniper Wolf had
received a temporary monetization
suspension over the Jax film situation
stating that off-platform actions that
put others personal safety at risk harm
the community and that the behavior from
both creators isn't what they want on
the platform initial responses included
that this is nothing more than a slap on
the wrist and confusion about what
YouTube meant by both creators not
behaving properly less than an hour
after YouTube's post Sniper Wolf shared
an apology to her Twitter in which she
said sorry for her recent actions to
Jack the community and her fans she said
she regretted not taking the opportunity
to show young creators how to resolve
conflicts professionally and hope she
could connect with Jack directly she
thanked YouTube for holding her
accountable and said she respected the
decision and the opportunity to grow
we're yet to hear from Jack's films on
all of this will he be sa satisfied with
YouTube not deplatforming Sniper Wolf
like he asked or with her apology we'll
let you know if this story
develops